can now speak to eken sue children
a British Turkish actress model and
television personality thank you very
much for being with us and I just well
Wonder first of all what do you make of
this awful disaster
it's honestly so heartbreaking because
it's it's my inheritage I'm Turkish and
I've got so many family and friends out
there and you know we always live on
edge in Turkey I lived in Turkey for two
years you just never know we any
movement we're always scared of the next
earthquake there was predictions made
you know many years ago that there'll be
a big earthquake in Istanbul I always
lived in fear when I lived in Istanbul
but the fact that this has hit many
cities and it's literally affected a big
capacity of turkey and Syria is is is so
sad so devastating and I just you know
we're all a nation we need to help each
other we need as much people to donate
and um and help everyone there's a lot
of bodies buried underneath those
buildings
and he recorded this appeal for the Red
Cross tell us about that
so I recorded that truly to speak up I
wanted to use my platform as I knew that
you know I had quite a big following and
I just wanted to reach out and support
obviously the British red red team and I
just wanted to make sure that you know
there is support out there we're trying
our best
to help you know we've got the first
injured AIDS set out there and um I just
want to help as much as I can I've you
know funded myself
um as many times as I could using the
website and I just wish a little bit of
anyone's help would would be great
because we need people to to save those
people that are buried under the ground
and why is it so important to you to do
that and do you think that you can reach
you know a much broader audience as it
were
that's right um I believe using
obviously my platform I wanted to reach
as many platforms as I could you know
anyone in the UK or whoever whoever was
following me from obviously what I was
on before and I just want to to shout
here again please help you know we've
got children families friends desperate
in need of your help
um I cannot emphasize this more it's
really sad it's really heartbreaking
we're a nation we're in this together
you know and um
yeah it's I'm lost for words it's it's
my it's my hometown it's my it's my
country you know
I wish I could be there right now
Yeah well yeah I was going to ask you
whether you might uh come across with
the Red Cross but I just wondered what
do you have friends and family who have
been directly caught up in this
so I have members of my family and who
have obviously experienced the shake
that they've been outside they've been
sleeping outside it's it's scary because
it's people who are very close to me you
know I've had numerous people um on
Instagram reach out to me they've sent
me locations of an address pictures live
and it's like they are screaming for
help and I want to use my platform as
much as I can to help you know anyone
out there from Syria and turkey
and of course that's the big fear here
in Turkey major earthquakes they live
with that fear
um you know all the time do you think
there's an issue about the preparedness
of the country four major earthquakes in
terms of building regulations and so
forth do you think there is an issue
about you know the way turkey is
prepared or not prepared for these
um events
I would like to to believe that certain
buildings which were built
um well are earthquake proof as I should
say but then some aren't and
unfortunately most parts of the
buildings are old in turkey and they're
very easily they can be damaged they can
crack and again if there is an
earthquake to to occur unfortunately
that's going to be destroyed but you
know Turkey is working the government is
working on making better uh buildings
more strong stable earthquake proof and
um I think that's the only way we can
move forward because
unfortunately you know earthquakes do
happen
um in turkey and Syria and and most most
countries almost every month but it's
the it's the big ones that scare us it's
the ones that you know we lose friends
family people that's the one that's
that's really scary
yeah and and certainly uh this was an
extremely powerful one just finally 30
seconds left
um you mentioned you'd like to be out
you know would you come out with the Red
Cross do you see there's a you know
there could be a purpose in that yes
as soon as the opportunity was given to
me I am there and obviously it's my home
it's my second language and anything I
can do I'm there to support anyone so
first opportunity I'll be there